today on the matt walsh show college
students get a professor placed on
indefinite leave for
referring to a racial slur not using one
referring to it on an exam that was
enough to get him on leave we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
aoc proving that she wants
unity by accusing ted cruz of attempted
murder and in our daily cancellation
i'm afraid we do have to talk about
covid anal swabs
all of that and much more today on the
matt walsh show
before we get started today i want to
tell you about our friends over at
expressvpn you know the fact is it's
very simple
everybody needs to be using a vpn big
tech companies have a ton of power in
our country today
we see that every single week it's a new
controversy it's it's something else
happening which proves this point yet
again
how exposed we are and how vulnerable we
are to them and as private entities they
can operate pretty much as they choose
you can protect your personal data from
big tech with the vpn
that i trust for my personal online
protection expressvpn
when i use expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted through their secure encrypted
servers to
these companies that can't see my ip
address at all
my internet activity becomes uh
anonymous and my network data is
encrypted
and so that i get the privacy that uh
that i deserve when i'm
using the internet that we all deserve i
recommend expressvpn to anyone who uses
the internet so
i mean that pretty much that means
everyone i recommend it to everyone the
best part is
you don't need to be tech savvy at all
to use expressvpn
i can tell you if you did have to be a
tech savvy to use it then
i wouldn't be using it so the fact that
i am means that you can too
just download the app on your phone or
on your computer tap one button and
you're protected it's really as simple
as that
visit expressvpn.com walsh to get three
extra months
free for a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash walsh to get three extra
months free expressvpn.com
walsh so i want to begin today by
discussing two stories that may at first
seem basically unrelated first we go to
politico where earlier in the week over
100 staffers signed a letter
and send it to their ceo further
expressing their outrage and grief over
the fact that ben shapiro wrote a
newsletter for them
that one time weeks ago uh yes you
remember that from weeks ago they're
still talking about it
even though two or three weeks have
passed since the offensive newsletter
which
was not offensive or provocative at all
still
these staffers have not overcome the
trauma that it caused them they demanded
an apology from their boss
along with treatment for their ptsd
which they say must include a dozen
therapeutic bunny rabbits in the office
which they can pick up and cuddle
anytime they feel scared
that last part is a joke but only barely
in the irony of all ironies
the letter also insists upon i'm not
kidding
greater workplace diversity yes they are
shouting for more diversity
while in the very same breath shouting
for less diversity
they are upset that somebody with
different views was allowed to write a
newsletter
and the reason they're upset they say is
that they want more
diversity but of course we understand
what they mean by diverse
diversity for them the perfect image of
diversity
what diversity is perfect image is a
room full of dozens of people of
different races
ethnicities genders and sexual
proclivities all
saying the exact same thing in unison
it's the kind of diversity that will be
best achieved once we're all replaced by
robots
which frankly at this point can't happen
soon enough so that's one story
let's look at another like i said these
these are related and i'll explain why
the daily wire has a report about a
university of illinois chicago law
professor jason kilbourne
the professor has been indefinitely
suspended after campus controversy that
stems originally
from a question on an exam now in the
exam
kilbourn presented to the students a
hypothetical case
dealing with race and gender
discrimination
okay now i imagine this is the kind of
thing that students in law
law school uh encounter a lot
hypothetical situations and cases that
they have to analyze
right so in this hypothetical case in an
employee quit her job
after um and now i'm going to read
directly from the exam text this is what
it says
after she attended a meeting in which
other managers expressed their anger
at plaintiff calling her an n
blank and b blank
that's what it says on the exam n and b
it does not say the word themselves it
just says n and b
with a little blank space next to each
letter this was enough to provoke
outrage the black law students
association spoke out claiming that
students were shocked and
distracted by the slur on the exam they
couldn't even take the test because they
were so they were so upset
even though again the slur was not
written out one student said she had
heart palpitations
just from seeing the letter n on the
page
let's hope that she never watches sesame
street when they get to you know today
today the letter is in
um a petition was was was circulated it
gained 400 signatures
demanding among other things that
kilbourne be forced to take cultural
sensitivity training
for writing the letter n on an exam
now you might ask how the hell can a law
professor even teach his students about
racial discrimination cases
if he can't so much as refer to a racial
if you can't even refer to a racial slur
then how can you communicate what to do
legally in these situations what if what
if he was what if this was a an oral uh
lecture and he had just said the n-word
not the actual word but he had said
quote the n-word would that have been
shocking and traumatizing too i suppose
so
meanwhile of course most of these
students listen to music every day
where the full word is said shouted
really over and over again that causes
them no emotional pain
but but someone with the wrong skin
pigmentation even so much as
refers to the word however indirectly
it'll cause them to collapse into tears
barely able to breathe
sure it's all completely absurd and it
only gets more absurd
here's what happened next kilbourne in
the midst of the great outrage over the
letter n
had a zoom meeting with a member of the
black law students association during of
course that conversation kilbourne was
asked
why the dean of the school had not given
killborn the petition
from the blsa so that he could read it
himself
and to that killborn joked that he
hadn't been given the letter
quote because uh is a quote i suspect
she's afraid if i saw the horrible thing
said about me in the letter i would
become homicidal
obvious joke but the blsa member who
heard this
promptly reported that comment to the
school's behavioral threat assessment
team at which point kilburn was placed
on indefinite leave
for threatening the students now
how does this relate back to the
political situation
because in the case of politico these
are alleged adults in the real world
behaving as though they are so
emotionally fragile
that they might dissolve into a puddle
if you so much as
give them a funny look in the case of a
law professor controversy these are
college kids with the same level of
emotional fragility
this yet again demonstrates an important
point that i've made before and i'll
make again
we assumed and declared for years
that the so-called snowflakes on college
campuses would would leave the pampered
confines of academia
go out into the real world experience a
rude awakening
and then after some painful adjustment
become mature and well-adjusted adults
that's that's what you know that's what
we assumed
wait wait till they get out into the
real world oh they're going to see how
it really works won't they
but that's not what happened instead
snowflakes have gone out into society
and remade it
in their own image as painful as it is
for us to acknowledge
they have not gotten the rude awakening
that we hoped and that they so much
deserve and there's no reason to think
they ever will
at least not in the way we thought they
would
this should have been an easy thing to
foresee in hindsight
a lot of things are easy to foresee in
hindsight
after all each generation inherits the
earth and makes society into what they
want it to be
if a bunch of emotionally stunted
overgrown babies take over
why would we think that they'd all
magically become mature adults
and besides this is not a process that
happened overnight and it didn't begin
with the millennial generation the
boomers collectively speaking
as a generation as much as they
complained about the millennials largely
have been
incompetent immature and selfish
themselves that's why they've ruined
every institution they've touched
and they're leaving the country in a
much worse state than it was when they
inherited it
the point simply is that many of the
rules
that make up the real world are
determined by society
now physical rules the laws of physics
and so forth are
independent of our whims and attitudes
obviously as much as we
these days like to pretend otherwise but
a rule like
society rewards maturity and
self-sufficiency
that kind of rule is certainly not
universal or innate
you have to build and maintain a society
that operates by that rule
if you don't then it won't unfortunately
in in our case we increasingly live in a
society that rewards and caters to
the loudest whiniest most selfish and
immature people
it's not just college campuses anymore
that work that way
one other point about this as i'm
thinking about it you know we've
probably also made a mistake
in using phrases like snowflakes as i
have here to describe the college kids
crying over a letter they read on an
exam or
staffers at uh politico writing a letter
to complain about a
ben shapiro article we call them
snowflakes well this implies that
they're merely sensitive
right they're they're too they're too
sensitive
and we've said that many times but the
truth is actually
almost the opposite of that because the
sensitivity is performative
what drives this is not sensitivity but
rather hatred
resentment a desire for power
was the black law students association
actually traumatized by the letter
n on a piece of paper do we really do we
believe that they
actually the student who said she had
heart palpation does anyone really
believe
that she's sincere when she said that or
did they see it as an opportunity to
vindictively assert their dominance over
and destroy a man they despise and the
spot despise in this case largely for
the color of his skin
and what they believe that color
represents i would say the latter
the snowflake act is just that it's an
act it's a tool
used by these so-called snowflakes to
get what they want it's a power play
and an extremely effective one it turns
out
so where do we go from here what do we
do with all this
what does it mean well all it means is
that our
problem is how society is fundamentally
constructed
no big deal that's it we we just have to
reconstruct society from the ground up
that's the
we can't wait for the real world to
solve the problems the real world has
been reshaped by these very same people
so we have to reconstruct it from the
ground up that's all it should only take
several generations to do
that's the good news and also the bad
news
but there's no time like the present to
get started
let's get now to our five headlines
man i don't know if you guys saw this
preview for uh godzilla versus king kong
that movie
or maybe it's king kong vs godzilla i
can't remember who gets top billing
um but uh it looks completely stupid
really entertaining also
and i i put it on for my kids
yesterday i put the preview on and my my
boys seven and four they lost their
minds watching it just
it was and i i thought back i i wish
when i was seven years old
what i would say it wasn't all that long
ago well it was still so long ago i
guess
but when i was seven you know king kong
if they made a king kong movie it still
would have been a guy in a suit
what i would have done to see a movie
like this king kong versus godzilla
remember can you imagine being a
seven-year-old boy in a movie like this
is coming up
but it also brings to mind because i'm
letting them watch this
and i i think this is something maybe
it's just me but
i actually think that all parents at
least talking to parents and thinking
about my own parents
all parents really struggle to come up
with a coherent
movie policy for their kids
and i think all parents end up making
these weird decisions where there's
certain movies or shows you won't let
your kid watch
and then other ones that are definitely
inappropriate you do let them watch like
my parents for example
uh you know there are so many shows they
would like cartoons they wouldn't let us
they wouldn't let us watch the simpsons
when i was a kid
but um i think i saw the exorcist when i
was like nine
and so with my kids it's kind of a
similar thing i'm very strict about
certain movies but i'll put on king kong
versus godzilla
i put on um the peter jackson king kong
that came out like in the early 2000s
for my my son when he was about five
i forgot there was a scene in that movie
where king kong literally bites a guy's
head off and spits it out
didn't remember that put it on i don't
know
you it's as a pair you just you just you
sort of fumble your way through these
things
and uh figure it out as you go along all
right this is number one from the daily
wire says new york's new york's death
toll from coronavirus
um from coronavirus related nursing home
deaths
may be much higher than what was
reported by the state especially in the
months after governor andrew cuomo
issued a mandate
requiring facilities to accept coveted
positive patients regardless of whether
those
facilities were equipped to handle them
you've heard a lot about that on this
show and other shows
um a report from new york attorney
general leticia james now so we knew
this was bad
but we knew that thousands of of elderly
people
died because of this policy what we're
finding out now
is that it's even worse than we thought
so attorney general leticia james has
determined that
cleveland 19 resident deaths associated
with nursing home nursing homes in new
york
appear to be undercounted by the doh by
approximately
50 percent that 50
refers to a narrow slice of data um
and uh goes on there getting into
specifics about it but
the headline here is that it's worse
than we thought it's a lot worse than we
thought and we already knew it was
pretty bad
this prompted cnn with their own
headline an article today it says
andrew cuomo's coven 19 performance may
have been
less stellar than it seemed oh you think
so cnn
yeah less stellar than it seemed to you
and to other diluted morons but to those
of us with our eyes open it was very
clear from the beginning that was not
stellar at all
because yeah he could he was giving
press conferences
and he had his uh you know his whole act
in the press conference where he
pretended to be this straightforward
tough talking guy
but those of us who are not extremely
stupid realize that
that has nothing to do with what he's
actually doing in relation to the
coronavirus
um but especially with cnn
see you say this now
but during the height of this
when uh when this was actually happening
when there were thousands of coveted
patients being put into these nursing
homes and this was going on
cnn now this was known we talked about
on this show we talked other shows
talked about it
we had articles about it on the daily
wire
but cnn rather than reporting on that
they had
andrew cuomo come on the air several
times a week
with his little brother and they have
these cutesy little back and forths
you know what was it the one time he
brought out a uh they were
a propped a prop q-tip to make fun of
the fact that uh andrew cuomo has big
ears and they had a big laugh about that
while elderly people were dying in
nursing homes due to andrew cuomo's
policies
so nice job cnn number two a moment of
unity
moment of unit unity ruined again
alexandria caser cortez
tweeted yesterday in response to uh news
about robin hood locking down their app
to stop users from buying more game stop
stock
um she said this is this was her
original tweet she said
this is unacceptable we now need to know
more about robinhood app's decision to
block retail investors from purchasing
stock while hedge funds are freely able
to trade the stock as they see it
as a member of the financial services
committee i'd support a hearing if
necessary
okay that's what she said and i agree
and i think most people
that this has been one issue where it
seems like
most people agree
with which is pretty impressive
because prior to this i wasn't sure if
there was anything ever again that we
could all agree on
but uh but with this with this issue
most people do well ted cru
ted cruz tweeted in agreement and all he
said was
i agree i think that was what his tweet
was and
kind of maybe extending a little bit of
an olive branch
aoc proceeded to take that olive branch
and
throw it in the incinerator this is what
she tweeted in response she said
i'm happy to work with republicans on
this issue where there's common ground
but you talking to ted cruz almost had
me murdered three weeks ago so you can
sit this one out
happy to work with almost any other gop
that aren't trying to get me killed in
the meantime
if you want to help you can resign
that's what she thinks of unity now by
the way when she said well i'm happy to
work with any other gop who didn't
try to get me killed what she fails to
mention is that she thinks they all
tried to get her killed she blames all
of them
with very maybe with the exception of
like mitt romney
um and a few others she she thinks they
all did
so what she means is i'm happy to work
with any other gop except for
all of the gop
you know and this is what there are two
things we take away from this first of
all
this is the point we've gotten to now
where a
a sitting member of congress accuses
another member of trying to have her
murdered
and it's like it's barely even news
even even ten years ago this would be
unheard of to have a claim like this
completely unsubstantive unsubstantiated
there's no basis for this whatsoever she
can't explain
in what way how so you're accusing him
of attempted murder
that seems to me to be defamation or
liable whichever one it is when you're
when you're saying it
or i guess in this case it's a tweet
i'll let the lawyers figure that out
but it seems to me that a claim like
this completely baseless false
smearing somebody uh trying to do them
damage
that doesn't seem legal to me
but we're at the point now where this
it's it's absolutely expected
and uh doesn't even doesn't even make
any waves oh yeah sure just a
congresswoman accusing a senator of
trying to have her killed
eh par for the course but also it shows
again
um what many on the left especially
democrats especially democrats like aoc
what they actually think of unity which
is that they have no interest in it
whatsoever
so there's really no point even when you
agree with them
there's no point in even saying it
there's
there's no point in trying to find
common ground
because you try to stay on the common
ground with them they're just going to
pull the rug out from under you
and kick you while you're down that's
what's going to happen
number three from the hill we knew this
was coming here it is um
president biden on president biden
i said resin resident biden actually
works i kind of like that
like a nursing home resident i think i
stumbled on
the resident biden i like that let's go
with that
resident biden on thursday signed two
executive actions focused on health care
describing the directives
as a necessary effort to undo the damage
done by
former president trump um biden signed
an order directing federal agencies to
open a special enrollment period for the
affordable care act
that he also signed a presidential
memorandum rescinding the mexico city
policy preventing federal funds
uh from going to organizations that fund
abortion overseas
and this is the great catholic the great
decent catholic joe biden
who is now going to force taxpayers he's
going to take food out of your
kids mouths to pay for abortions
overseas is what's going to happen
now we got here he is signing this order
but you'll notice something and he's
kind of explaining why he's signing it
but you'll notice something about this
explanation
maybe it'll jump out at you listen the
second
order i'm going to be signing also
changes what the president has done
president of the president what former
president has done
and that a memorandum reversed the
my predecessor's attack on women's
health
extreme health access and
as we continue to battle cover 19
even more critical americans have
meaningful access to health care
if we could just move past the irony of
him hacking up a lung while he says the
word health
uh but moving past that he he's talking
about funding abortions overseas but he
won't say it
he won't even say the word abortion said
he talks about women's health
talks about it in a very roundabout way
and one of the reasons that that he
still comes from that old school
democrat mentality uh old school meaning
like 20 years ago where radically
pro-abortion but they won't say it they
won't they won't say the word
and i think it's because they still have
a little bit they still have a little
bit of shame in them and they realize
that it's a shameful thing
so they don't want to openly acknowledge
it
now the newer democrats have no problem
talking about abortion they're proud of
it
in the end it all ends with the same
policies and it ends with the same
body count of children being killed so
it doesn't matter that much
but for him he won't even just come out
and say oh yeah this is for so we're
going to fight abortions overseas
and that should tell you something when
there's a certain policy in the people
and many of the people who support
the policy and the guy who's signing the
policy
enacting it doesn't want to talk about
it
doesn't even want to say the word well
that should tell you something
you notice that with uh interesting
dichotomy right between pro-lifers and
pro-abortion people
because with pro-lifers we don't we
don't use any euphemisms we speak about
this issue directly
we are not afraid at all to say what we
really think and to to to just talk
about this issue in a direct
straightforward manner it's always been
the pro-abortion side
many of them anyway though i say not all
of them it's always been many of them
that they feel that we need to dance
around it to find all these different
euphemisms these different terms women's
health reproductive health
and any time you see that even if you
don't know anything about the issue
you know nothing about the issue but you
don't know what abortion is
and you hear two sides arguing about it
and one side is talking about it
directly and the other side is
is doing anything they can to not speak
about it directly that's enough right
there to tell you
who's on the right side all right number
four
i have to do this i'm sorry i have to do
it i take no pleasure in this at all
um but i gotta i have to play for you
because i was subjected to it this is
kristin
chenoweth she's a broadway actress
uh and she she made a song a
broadway-style song about camila harris
and i'm gonna play it for you just
because here it is
her name is
it's someone named kamala and truly
since i've begun
to learn all she's done i see she
deserves that spot
and also i learned it's no not kamala so
think
popularity will grow cause we know
how much she's gonna be helping joe
after all there is nobody a student
when she was a prosecutor tough
but fair she really found her niche and
then she fought for right then justice
rick
came to serving in the senate
where i come from she'd make a very good
witch
i agree with the last part very good
witch
i i lost my will to live while watching
that
i felt myself plunging into the depths
of despair
i can't even it's something about that
that's so
horrendously depressing
and they're still trying to do this with
it's it will never stop being funny to
me
this enthusiasm they're trying to
generate for this woman
that they didn't care at all about
they she could have been president
if you care so much about you you're
literally singing songs about her now
you're so excited
but where was this excitement a year ago
now she's only the pseudo print now
she's the president behind the scenes
while senile joe is there as the
figurehead but she could have been
the main person she could have been the
boss officially
top of the ticket look you guys
chose the old 78 year old white man
and now you want to pretend you're
excited about it sorry i don't buy it
i especially don't buy it in that form
all right number five
this is from the new york post it says
two california women claim that
subway's tuna sandwich actually contains
not a scintilla of the fish
that they were duped by the fast food
joints claims
and they're saying this in a five
million dollar lawsuit
karen uh donoa and nalima ayman
both of alameda county california say
they ordered tuna from the sandwich
giant locations near their home as
recently as last year
this is according to the federal lawsuit
but independent testing has repeatedly
affirmed the products are made from
anything but tuna
the filing of the products has no
scintilla of tuna at all the suit claims
in fact subways tuna is made from a
mixture of various concoctions
that do not constitute tuna that have
been blended together by the defendants
to imitate the appearance of tuna
this is a kind of a form of as a
cultural pro is an appropriation
of tuna by this imposter
the filing alleges that subway has done
this in an effort to save money since
the blended non-tuna product costs less
i'm trying to get to the point in this
article where they explain why they
deserve
five million dollars because they got
fake tuna
i mean have they bought five million
dollars worth of tuna sandwiches
because if they have then i would say
they apparently they don't hate the tuna
that much
but i'm i'm okay with this if if you're
gonna file the lawsuit against subway
though the only thing i'll say if we're
filing a lawsuit against subway
uh i would rather or maybe this is
something that would come out in the
discovery phase i don't know but
but uh one way or another i want to know
what the smell is
in a subway sandwich shop when you walk
in
there is a smell and i've asked this
question before i've asked it in subways
before
what the smell is you know what i'm
talking about if you've ever been in a
subway there's a very distinct smell
and it's not terribly pleasant
this kind of it's this it's it's it's
not
it's not exactly like walking into a
into a you know a dumpster
not exactly that but there's this
waff that you smell when you walk in
it's kind of just a disturbing i don't
know what it is exactly
and the answer i've been given is that
it's the smell of baked bread
no no i know the smell of baked bread
and that ain't it
i don't know if it's congealed lunch
meat mixed with the bread mixed with
uh the smell of the of the of the
bathroom i don't know what it is
but that's what i want to know with with
the subway
well the most important things that we
can do for ourselves is to
always strive to know more information
to learn more you know to keep whether
whether you went to college or you
didn't go to college or if you're maybe
you're still in school doesn't matter
um learning is not something we should
do just at school we got to continue
doing that throughout our lives to
become more well-rounded and interesting
people
and that's why great courses plus i
cannot recommend
enough i use it myself i've been a big
great courses fan for a long time
with great courses plus you get
unlimited streaming access to thousands
of video lectures on virtually anything
that interests you i mean really
anything at all you just gotta go check
it out yourself any topic
you learn how to master tai chi or
public speaking
uh you could learn oceanography you
could learn about history you can learn
learn how to read body language
anything at all whatever you happen to
be interested in
the great courses plus has something for
everyone and it's all thoroughly vetted
back-based information um and it's you
know it's not you're not you're not
sitting down and reading
you know just a wikipedia article this
is not this is not wikipedia education
this is
thorough it's going to give you a real
understanding of the topic
and when you download the great courses
plus app you can watch or listen to
any device anytime anywhere
i've like i said i've listened to a lot
of great courses
over the last several years especially
one of the most recent ones i listened
to was a professor by the name of robert
sapolsky
and he had a lecture on biology and how
it determines
its relationship to human behavior yeah
i also like to listen to
courses on on history and you know
astronomy and all these different kinds
of things anything at all
with great courses what purpose waits
for you sign up for the great courses
plus to find out i have a special url
that you can use the
greatcoursesplus.com
wall so i'll say that again
thegreatcoursesplus.com walsh
you get a full month of unlimited access
for free
don't miss out on this trust me again
that's
dot thegreatcoursesplus.com slash walsh
another thing you don't want to miss out
on
is our new feature film run hide fight
daily wire you know we're getting
into the culture we're taking back the
culture and that includes entertainment
that's a really important part of this
so um if you're not a daily wire member
yet use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off
we've told you if you if you're
listening to what the mainstream critics
have to say
then um then you know you're not going
to want to watch the movie but don't
listen to the mainstream critics if you
go to rotten tomatoes
you know run hide and fight has a 93
rating among the audience 2 000 audience
reviews
the mainstream critics give it 27 okay
now if you want to know why you
shouldn't
you know who you should trust think
about the movie cuties remember that on
netflix
that uh that disgusting movie that has
an 87
rating with mainstream critics 15 with
the audience so the audience knows what
it's doing
i don't know about the critics though
run hide fight again if you're not a
daily wire
member yet become a member use promo
code rhf to get 25 off that's rhf for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
i never thought i had to say this but
today we're going to cancel anal swabs
the media has been reporting that china
in order to test for covid
is now using both throat and anal swabs
though not on the same person or at
least not with the same swab
one would hope in any case the
washington post has this they say the
people of china could be forgiven for
thinking they'd seen it all during the
chronovirus pandemic but now
they face a new indignity the addition
of anal swamps chinese state media
outlets
introduced the new protocol in recent
days prompting widespread discussion and
some outrage
uh only some outrage apparently in china
some chinese doctors say the science is
there recovering patients they say have
continued to test positive through
samples from the lower digestive tract
days after nasal and throat swabs came
back negative
yet for many it seemed to step too far
in government intrusion after a year in
counting
of a dignity eroding pandemic everyone
involved will be so embarrassed
one user of um the chinese social media
app weibo said
even chinese doctors who support the new
test said the method's inconvenience
meant it made sense for use only in
select groups such as at quarantine
centers
that's what they say but it seems the
anal swab technique is
not only being used on people in
quarantine centers
even airline passengers are apparently
required to subject themselves to this
experience
the hill reports quote nose and anal
swabs were taken from a group of
passengers on a flight from
chiang chong china to beijing on monday
other travelers arriving in beijing
have also been asked to use anal swabs
one woman
who was not identified by name
thankfully for her
was asked to use an anal swab in a
mandatory hotel quarantine in beijing
alongside several nose and throat tests
and a blood test again we hope that they
use different equipment for all those
different tests
it's not clear to me whether this
swabbing is happening in the airport or
on the plane
in most cases or somewhere else perhaps
they do it while you're waiting in line
at the food court burger king
for efficiency's sake at least the mask
will help hydra shame a little bit
there's been a video making the rounds
which appears to be some sort of chinese
official or doctor in an airport
demonstrating the anal swab technique
thankfully he's using a dummy
in this case um the good news is that
this is all only slightly more invasive
than what the tsa already does
i mean it's hard to believe that a
little more than
20 years ago you could walk into an
airport
get right on a plane carrying a baseball
bat and a knife if you wanted i mean
literally you could actually bring that
stuff on a plane
now they confiscate your water bottles
and subject you to a rectal
probe we have come a long way
in the wrong direction now
i haven't done any official polling on
this but based on informal conversations
it appears that
it appears that most people are rather
opposed to the anal swab method
the approval rating for anal swabs is
rather low it's almost as low as the
approval rating for congress
why is that i mean why do people recoil
at the idea
well i think they recoil at it for a few
reasons
one of them though perhaps the number
one is that dignity matters
as it turns out and that's the takeaway
here
if there's any lesson to be learned from
anal swabs anal swabs are an extreme
example
but why you know do most people reject
the idea because they want to preserve
their dignity
even if that form of testing is more
accurate even if it would make us safer
who knows maybe it would i don't know
doesn't matter
most of us would say because we have our
dignity and we would like to preserve it
thank you
there have to be limits okay there are
things that i will not have
that i will not subject myself to things
i will not cooperate with simply because
i'm a human being and i have dignity
dignity is actually a more important
consideration
than safety if there's a choice between
staying safe and forfeiting your dignity
or keeping your dignity and forfeiting
your safety
you should go through door number two
every time
so we see that i think with extreme and
absurd things like anal swabs
i just wish we could see it with things
that are only slightly less extreme and
absurd
like wearing a mask while walking
outside or wearing two masks or three
masks
or wearing a mask and a visor
when you when you go to walmart now
maybe you'll be a little safer
if you do that maybe the person with the
mask and the gloves and the visor is a
little safer maybe
maybe if you wear a mask while you go
for a jog you're a little bit safer i'm
not convinced that's true actually but
but maybe it is for the sake of argument
say it is you're a little bit safer so
what
i still won't do it because it's
undignified it's ridiculous it's
humiliating
that's my reason my reason is actually
not oh it's it's it's because of the
science it's actually got nothing to do
with science
i just think it's humiliating ridiculous
and it looks stupid and uh it's
undignified that's why i'm not gonna do
it
we've been told that that's that's
that's not a good reason you need a
better reason no i think that's the best
reason
i think it's one of the best reasons you
can have for doing or not doing
something
now if you don't think it's a good
reason dignity isn't a good reason
to not do something okay well then ask
for the anal swab next time you're
getting tested
next time you're at cvs getting the
covet test ask if they have the anal
swap
it'll make you safer dignity doesn't
matter does it
i say it does which is why anal swabs
along with so many other anti-covet
measures
are canceled and incidentally i have now
used the term anal swab
more times in the last five minutes than
i had through my whole life to this
point
these are not the sorts of personal
milestones that i set out to achieve but
uh
what can we do that's where we are
and we'll leave it there for today great
note to end on
um for the week have a great weekend
talk to you on monday
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. internet
savvy investors cost
short selling financial pros 70 billion
dollars
the establishment takes extraordinary
measures to stop ordinary people from
making money
and aoc demonstrates how little the left
wants unity check it out on the michael
knowles show